how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have 12 days until Avengers in game
hits theaters if you're going to see it
on the 25th the day before it comes out
13 days if you're going to see it on the
26th and with everything that we've
gotten for Avengers in games so far it
seems like a lot of our favorite heroes
are getting some upgrades Iron Man is
going to get his mark 85 on Man suit
that we've already seen in the trailers
we know that we're going to get a
variation of Professor Hulk
we know that Captain America gets his
shield back and will most likely be
upgraded thanks to Tony Stark and even
Hawkeye is becoming Ronin so in this
video I'm going to talk about Thor's new
upgrade in Avengers in game real quick
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe if you want to stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers in
game and all things Marvel also I do
monthly giveaway is currently giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and
a glow-in-the-dark painting of Thanos by
Globe I bow I'll talk more about the
giveaway at the end of the video so
Thor's upgrade is something that I think
a lot of people have forgotten about or
just simply don't know about and that is
Megan yarn for those of you who are not
familiar with what Megan yarn is it is
not another axe it's not a hammer it's
not a spear it's a belt I don't think
that Thor will be getting a new hammer
in Avengers in a game because
Stormbreaker is already insanely
powerful however there is a need for an
upgrade with Thor because Stormbreaker
is not as powerful as the Infinity
Gauntlet
yes Stormbreaker did overpower Thanos
and the Infinity Gauntlet in Avengers
infinity war however the recent brothers
who directed the film explained to us
why and basically what they said is that
Thor caught Thanos off-guard if Thanos
would have known what was happening he
could have used the Infinity Gauntlet to
easily overpower Thor which makes
perfect sense because he had all of the
stones in the gauntlet so there is a
need for Thor to get some kind of an
upgrade but Stormbreaker in the MCU is
probably the strongest hammer Thor will
ever get Eitri said that it was a weapon
made for the king of Asgard so there's
probably not another weapon that Eitri
could make that would be stronger than
Stormbreaker except for maybe another
Infinity Gauntlet however there is
something that could make Thor even
stronger than he is now and that is
Maegan yarn his magical belt and Meaghan
actually already exists in the MCU and
is on earth in fact it's at the Avengers
headquarters in spider-man far from home
we heard happy Hogan talk about loading
up Captain America shield and Thor's new
belt
Megan yarn so Thor's going to be in the
same exact place as his magical belt
Megan yarn we've already seen Thor at
the Avengers headquarters in all of the
trailers although we're not quite sure
why Tony Stark had Megan yarn the most
popular theory is that Thor simply left
the belt there in anticipation that he
would return to earth one day which is
something that has been done before in
Captain America the First Avenger we saw
that as Guardians left a tesseract on
earth so for those of you wondering what
exactly Megan or does it's an enchanted
belt of strength and when Thor puts it
on he has two times the power that he
normally has in the comics the belt is
usually held in Odin's vault and only
really comes out during really desperate
times
one of the biggest times being where he
wore it to boost his powers and make his
god blast he released his God blast from
mule near in an attempt to breach the
impenetrable armor of the celestial exit
are without Stormbreaker or meal near
Thor didn't really put up much of a
fight against Thanos in the beginning of
infinity war however once he got
Stormbreaker he was obviously much
stronger and was able to take on Thanos
but like the Russo brothers said he took
him by surprise and the gauntlet is
definitely more powerful than storm
breaker but Thor being at two times his
original strength could definitely be
enough to finally kill Thanos but let me
know what you all think about this do
you think that Thor is going to put on
Megan yard and Avengers in game let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway for the
Infinity Gauntlet and the
glow-in-the-dark Thanos painting by
globe I bow you can also find more of
his work at globe I bow comm I'll put it
in the description down below and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
and all things Marvel as always thank
you all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]